double jeu antenne 2 aux folies bergères
tous les samedis soirs ça alors je vais
dire à marc pas me payer charline
gabonais de la télé donc walemme ce que
je fais votre femme a pas du tout mais
quand même agréable quand je vous dois
chapais 65,53 te les garder tous messi y
est je vous embêtera pas de me signer un
petit autographe
quand votre femme alors pour les gosses
j'adore les clowns mais heureusement de
superstition vexé ces belles comment vos
gosses david et jonathan
voilà merci je suis sympa je dis c'est
quoi cette signature là bas c'est vrai
ça pourquoi vous pourriez pas signé
chambre il faut être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu